in this video i'm going to show you how
to call a javascript function in the
browser but from java running on the
server side
and the other way around how to call a
java method in the server
from a javascript function
all right so i have this project here
and in fact there are many projects
because uh this is part of my upcoming
book on vadim but this is the important
one this is just a valid project with
one class with one view
that extends vertically out and it's a
this
mapped to this route so let's create a
new
button here that says
toggle and let's assign this to a new
variable
and a new image as well um
so i guess this requires this the source
and the alt
okay so i'm going to grab the link from
here from the open jdk
page copy image link very uh
cheerful duke
and maybe we want to make this image
with full maybe that's
a good idea and of course we need to add
the button and the
image to the vertical layout so let me
open a
web browser over here and
let's request that view don't show this
again
yeah so it's working now what we want to
do is we want to call
a javascript function from here this is
server side java
and so for that we need to create first
a new
javascript file here in front end so i'm
going to call it
script.js make sure that you are adding
it
here there we go
let me move this over there so we can
see the java code at the same time
and we need to load that file with j
as module and what's called script.js
okay so now we can we can define the
function here so you might think it's a
good idea to just
go ahead and create a function like this
function
let's say toggle and we pause the
element
right but in fact what we want to do is
add a new object to the window
scope if you wish and let's move this
over here and so the notation
should change to this because it's an
object and
so this object is going to be a function
and now we can implement the
the functionality to toggle the
visibility let's say of this
image and i'd like to use jquery
so we need to load jquery the way you do
it is
the same it's actually a script and i'm
going to get it from here i have the
page
ready let's copy this
link that is jquery and now we can use
jquery
here so let me select the
element and i think it's a fade
toggle i hope that's the correct one
um i think it is well
we can we can just try here so we want
to call that function
when we click this button it's a button
that add
click listener event and here we're
going to call that
that function so how to do that
ui.getcurrent.getpage
execute js and here we can put any
javascript javascript expression so we
need to use this
namespace dot toggle and we pass the
parameter
so the parameters we will specify them
here i need to pass the
what we need to toggle which is the
image and i need to specify the position
here starting with
zero the position here in this list of
parameters
um so you're of course gonna use one two
three if you have more
parameters here right like this would be
the parameter one
two etc
okay very good i think um this should
work let's see if this
restarted automatically there we go
so now we can toggle the um
cheerful duke very good
um
what else can we do here
how about returning something if we want
to return
for example new date dot
oh let's use i guess this
that should be a string uh how can we
use that
that value here in the
in the server side so if you if you have
a look at
this method it returns a pending
javascript result
that means we need to use the
then method let me format this a little
bit
and we have the result here result that
we can use for example notification
not show
result as
string let me format this again okay
uh so that's that's how you use uh the
[Music]
the return
value from the function but there is a
there's a there's a problem still so let
me refresh this to reload everything
you will see that this is no
so it's not really taking that it's
because this result is the
return value
from this expression and this is not
returning anything
we need to say return
some value all right so remember
to put this return here
now let's let's try that again toggle
now we'd see
that it shows the the date very good
okay how about the other way around how
can we call
a java method from javascript
so let's let's um explore that for
example let's say we want to add a click
listener to this of course you can add
it
just uh with add
click listener button we wouldn't learn
much
if we do it that way so i want to add a
click listener here in javascript to
this element
and um and then call
call the server okay so for example we
want to call
a new function uh sorry method here
uh show note or let's say click
notification and we can pass the
coordinates of the click event
and we can show the notification here
that
show actually let's do it
in a nicer way message equals
string dot format
clicked at then some number
and another number x
y and we showed that message
so we want to call that that method from
here
in order to enable that we need to mark
this with a
client callable otherwise we won't be
able to
do it
[Music]
and let's create for example we can
create a new
init function here that receives
the element that's gonna uh kind of
receive the clicks
but we need also something
to be able to call this show click
notification method
and so that's gonna be the view because
it's in the view after all right
it's in this class so it makes sense
now we want to take this element and on
click we're going to
say that this is a javascript
we're going to say that um
we want to call the server we want to
call this
so way to do that so we take the view
and vadim adds
something special here which is called
server with that notation
so dollar sign or money sign and then
server then we can call
this method right there and pass for
example
event dot
client x event client
y and um
and yeah i think that should work we
need to add a coma here because these
are
this is kind of a map right it's a
javascript object
and i think that should be let's try it
out
okay it's not working let's investigate
uh oh of course
we're creating this uh function but
we're not calling the function to init
to initialize the the the logic here to
add this click
listener so we need to do it so we
already know how to do that
get current get page execute
js um
name space in it and then we
it's this time we need two two
parameters so
um zero and one
and the first one was the element the
i forgot to close this string the
element is the image
and the view is this
so that should do the trick let me
format this maybe
and click now it works
all right that was fun uh thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you